you can feel the desperation right now  they're starting to lose  give you the whistle Indies don't worry  I'm drowned or one-possession sorry so I  see under why she liked me some town in  the water  I just bought a Cuban dicta and a foul  and everywhere  I go listen lace your arms around it  Busta Busta Busta Busta I'm drowning  I just bought a Cuban ring and dipped it  in the fountain so happy I feel like I'm  holding up a show I'm surrounded push  down push down pass down bus stop bus  dump jump down and I'm wait all mine I  don't go nowhere without them if they  don't let us in they make those shots at  the bouncer activist medicine got it  straight from mouth the doctors I'm with  Archie but I call him Wayne cuz he's a  shot